ok next game um I'm playing black um the
point is called Pro Felix ice a
grandmaster from pollicis norway norway
i forgot the name our life Oh God ok
let's go for mmm benko again ok declines
it not f3 so okay IFIF is a Muslim
principled move I don't know it so maybe
you can transpose to Raja bind no ok
then we got some symmetrical English
III looks like a strange move to me long
diagonal ok at least I can get rid of
some pieces now the usual answer to this
often is some 925 but now this would
just drop material or I know I thought
Bishop takes Knight h5 but it's got
greedy fo check ok he places anyway
still makes a strange impression if you
ask me but ok ok put again I can simply
castle as well
compared to two other positions in this
symmetrical kind of setup I'll get some
exchanges in I only need to be cautious
about the C file for instance if i take
with the bishop now and why now remove
the night to exchange them the bishop I
need to be cautious that at some point
is in my place bishop h3 and get the
square c 8 but should be should be
manageable i think okay take so with the
bishop okay of course you can do that
okay let's get rid of more pieces here
so general belam a good idea yeah what
tends to be a bit better than this kind
of position the bishop is just the
stronger piece at least as long as there
are on heavy pieces around if it gets
exchanged down a bit it's it's no big
big deal for black a pure minor PSN game
might even be promising okay maybe he's
trying to get something going with rook
h 4f four to-to give an exchange there
it's possible something like this okay
with Ruby ADA intended to play b5 he
didn't do anything against it yeah I
can't believe this isn't a threat here
okay lets some try to prepare be five
more
really queen h6 look edge for us maybe
maybe as possible okay I need to get
some card to play here yet so it's very
straightforward you don't think this
should lead to anything special but okay
I can do this okay let's say let think
what what about a form may be a form is
this is really dangerous tweenage 6,000
g4g 5pm there maybe maybe it is
dangerous
hey good beam okay I show me if this is
really really great then well played he
insists okay can I capture first on b3
usng for already ready winning us
something ok ok ok let's let's bring the
Queen to f8
I am down to 118 some I really need to
speed up here okay it's really playing
this okay okay yeah I don't want to
capture with rock if you place g5 now
okay night h5 I need to sacrifice the
spawn but his rook is terribly misplaced
there so shouldn't be a big deal need to
exchange are here first maybe a for now
it's an idea oh maybe this was
interesting okay cross cover h7 and now
I'll get get my pawn back at least I'm
still one paw down but g5 is hanging and
ties this one is of course also we can
just go here I forgot about this this
stupid trick okay check this was really
unnecessary
check check check yes looks like I'm
losing this game was this true just
completely unnecessary I just needed to
one hour to exact moves and then it's
just nothing the sole plan with luggage
for Queen h6 is just just you but I
think now every major yeah completely
completely useless lossy em ação xenium
black cannot stop f3 mate just need one
exact move or something and this is just
just nothing yeah just Roxy five maybe
I can also simply am I can't play
anything here Roxy 3 Roxy too it's all
great except what I play it in yeah just
just I just played this bad i didn't i
didn't really take this one into account
and now i should play rock edge ADM and
still still somewhat tough i think but
of course there's also there's already
something has gone wrong already here
yeah okay this was just a bad game on my
side